From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American History and Culture.
Okay.
This is today's Thursday, July 14, 2011.
My name is Cheryl Manier of the Southern Oil History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill,
with the video art for John Bishop on the campus of the University of Maryland, both more counting to do an interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African-American History and Culture.
And today we'll look at Dr. Freeman Ravasque and I must say it's a real privilege and honor, so thank you so much for sitting down.
Thank you.
Let me have you start if you would, just with the description of family, community, and Birmingham,
on the upper edge of your board in August of 1950.
Sure.
I honestly believe I was as fortunate as a child could be, a child of color, could be born in the 1950s.
I had parents who were educated, who were older and who had been married ten years.
And so they were really looking for me, fine Christian people, very hard working, and we lived in a middle class neighborhood with similar families.
The emphasis was on education, on our faith, on values, and on building strong community among the people in that area.
That was my background in Birmingham.
The church was at the center of everything.
Which church?
Sixth Avenue Baptist Church, the sister church to the one that was bombed actually in Birmingham.
Tell me a little more about your mother and your father and kind of your new sister building back.
Sure.
Sure. My mother and father grew up in rural areas and as was the case with so many people in the big city, they had come off of farms.
My mother was born in 1916, my father was born in 1910.
And they had actually met in college.
My dad had been away teaching because you could teach after two years, had come back and it was in 1938.
My mother had transferred from Alabama and I'm wish had gotten the first two years because that was as far as they went at that time.
And she wanted to continue on to get the bachelor's and so they met in Montgomery at Alabama State.
A few blocks from the capital there and they were married in 1940.
And when it come from, we tumke, Alabama, which is outside of Montgomery.
And my father had come from Saudi-Salam, Atlanta, Lowns County, outside of Selma, in fact.
And my father had lived on land that was a part of a larger plantation which had been a part of his family.
And it was my father Freeman, the second whose grandfather was the son of the plantation owner.
And my grandfather Freeman, the first was the first one born after slavery.
And if you think about it, it literally was from the 1870s.
So my dad in 1910 and then he was 40 when I was born and it's right there.
So you have that period very quickly.
And your father's employment in Birmingham and you were born was becoming a part of your career?
My father had been a teacher but you could make a lot of money as a man of color teaching.
And so he left it to work in the steel mill because you could make much more money over time.
But dad had special skills. He was really good at reading in mathematics.
And so not only did he work in the steel mill but he did the reading and writing for his white supervisor who did not have a high school education.
Behind the scenes he did that work and got paid for it.
And then he worked for the railroad and he also did some of the reading and writing for a supervisor there.
And then he worked with the families who were grieving in a funeral.
So my dad worked three jobs. My mother worked three jobs.
She taught in the day and later on taught also GED in the evenings, math and English.
And she sold insurance and she tutored kids and sold snowballs in the summertime.
So they were very entrepreneurial.
What you know, stock and bavain fittings.
Stock and bavain fittings. And my mother was at a school very close, shelled elementary.
But we grew up in one of the two middle class neighborhoods of Birmingham.
We grew up in Titusville, TITU, SVL, E, the other neighborhood of course was Smithville.
And it was a very special place.
I had a cousin who my parents adopted who grew up with him.
Tell me a little more about the rhythm and culture of middle class black life in Birmingham in the 50s, especially around church and neighbors and extended band.
We seemed to always be in church. And children really didn't want to be there.
But we were very involved in all kinds of activities. The youth fellowship, Baptist training units, you know, the choir, going on trips and camps, Bible school.
And it was just a part of home but it was not necessarily what we would have wanted to be doing.
But it was what was expected. So you just did it. You did it in the summer during the year.
But I would also say we were in and out of other homes. And others were essentially parents too.
And we were learning much about our values and expectations.
As much from other parents, that's from our own.
What was your pastor?
Reverend John T. Porter.
Now, he came when I was 12. Before him, it was Reverend Good Game.
But at age 12, he came back from Detroit. But he was a favorite son. He had grown up in that church.
He had gone, gone to Alabama State himself and had the Morehouse experience and was an incredible man.
He came back. He was 32 and I was 12. And he was an incredible pastor. I think my speaking skills come from listening to him all the time.
And he was amazingly accessible. He spent a lot of time with the teenagers, with the kids, talking about everything in ways that even our parents wouldn't talk about them.
And it just made us very close to him. He and his wife, in fact, she had graduate degrees in music and voice from NYU.
And so our church was very cultured, as we would say in a South. We grew up with piano lessons and you'd hear Bach in church.
And so it was different from what the larger society may have thought always happened. It really shows the diversity within the Black community.
Indeed, and I wanted to ask a couple of things. One is looking back. Did your family have a wide array of neighbors, family, persons through the church who had a wide class background?
It's fascinating question. This is very middle class. But understand something. The middle class had people with graduate degrees and the few lawyers and physicians.
But the middle class also included people who worked for very wealthy whites. It was very interesting.
So if someone was not educated, that person was still very polished because they had been around the best of whites.
And so they might travel to Europe with their employees. And they were the beneficiaries of the exposure that wealthy whites were getting.
And so they had their own contribution to the community in very interesting ways. So we had a combination. Most were teachers.
Teachers and the women were teachers. In some cases the men were teachers. But sadly, if you wanted to make more money, unless you were a principal, and then you made a bit more money.
And we had principals in the neighborhood. But so you had that kind of... Now I will say my parents were constantly helping people who were not educated.
We were constantly working with kids to get them into college. My mother would fill out the financial aid forms all the time and work with them on applications and essays. But even more than that, because my mother worked on the GED, she was working with parents of kids and pushing families to send their kids to college.
And not just relatives, but people in general. And my father was very good at advising men. Women would always say, you need to go talk to them. And in Birmingham, the name was pronounced robust.
You see, I say robust because of Polish professors that your name is not robust, but this family. But there, often my parents served as advisors or counselors to merit couples when they were having problems.
So they were everything from merits counselors to helping people get into college.
Did you get into the title of the church? He was a decon. And I'll tell you what was significant about 6th Avenue. When they were building this really big church, when we were moving from 6th Avenue and 16th Street South to the Titusville area, more so, in a modern church, because UAB was going to be taking over all that area.
A number of the families were asked to put up their mortgages for the church. And there is a wall in the church with those family's names. This is how closely connected the church and the families were.
And one of the great prides of Birmingham was that the Birmingham, I guess the paper, the Birmingham News, is the big white paper, had published an article on the front page of the paper, which is very unusual. The Birmingham World was the black paper. So we were constantly being there.
But the Birmingham News published a piece, the front page story at the top there, that at one point, in the late 50s and early 60s, before the civil rights movement, as we think about it in the early 60s, that we had more Negroes who owned their homes than any city in the country.
Now, owning their homes meant they were buying their homes, they had the mortgages right, but they were not renting. And it was because of this robust economy involving the steel mills and the teachers.
And so that was the greatest proud of any family to own a home. And a home with two or three bedrooms, big deal. And as we, as the time went on, the two and three bedroom homes added on a room, they extra-din, middle class America.
And, but the homes were the symbol of the status.
And of course, this is before all of the economy, the industrial economies evolving. It's still very well-known.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
In that kind of urban context, would you have had white acquaintances coming up?
Oh, absolutely not. I had never met anyone white. I simply knew that white children were considered smarter than black children.
And so many of them were told that in so many ways, in subtle ways. The first time I realized just how distinct the two groups were, and distinctly hierarchical, was I was peeling back the brown paper-sector bag cover of the book I've been given in the second grade.
I believe it alone. And I peeled it back and I saw the name of the white school. And I went up and asked the teacher, why did they give us the second hand books?
Because that was such a message to us, you see. Of course, when I teach the first set, we told you not to peel the paper back so I was in trouble.
But what she said was the same thing my parents always said. And I've said this so many times. She said, you don't have time to be a victim.
Get over it. You don't have time to be a victim. The book may be second rate. You are first rate. You are a child of God. Get the knowledge and keep moving.
Powerful, powerful message. Which I didn't want to hear because I wanted- I was upset.
And while it may seem that she was being harsh, she was preparing me for life. Absolutely preparing me for life. Focus on the real things and things that you can change.
We're back after a very short break. Dr. Balsky, I wanted to ask- you were just mentioning schools.
But before we do that, you're also mentioning this political, that's quite the right word, but this message that a teacher gives to you about.
We're in the circumstance that we're going to forge ahead with this side of the certain, you know, certain motive practice.
Was your house, were your parents, was your church community sort of actively political and say through the racial questions of the 50s?
Is that something that was around your dinner table? Did you hear from the pulpit or-
We heard about political issues and race matters all the time. My parents enjoyed being race people.
I think my mother was probably most proud. It was proudest of the fact that she had been fired in another school system because she tried to organize teachers in the late 40s to protest or to demand equalization of teacher salaries.
This is outside of Birmingham, one of the systems right outside of Birmingham. People were appalled that she would do that.
But as she said, she was just foolish enough to try and she was indeed fired. But she was such a good teacher that within a short period.
This was right before 1950 and I know it because she wasn't teaching long. She got it job in Birmingham City, which was really the plum place.
Right? And then we called him the Negro Superintendent. He was the director of Colott Schools for a week. Dr. Carol Hayes hired her.
He liked that mother because she was very smart, very smart and very comfortable with herself.
And he hired her and she worked there until she retired in Birmingham.
Well, late 40s was the time when those equalizations efforts were underway because, obviously, stakes were trying to make it somehow fend off.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
How about you father?
My father did several things. He was working with the men in the steel mill to get them to get their GEDs.
So he tutored them, particularly in math. That was always very good in math. He always loved teaching.
So he was constantly working with these guys. And he wrote the Negro section of the Bulletin.
Actually, still have copies. And they were lessons about life. But there was this Bulletin from the company, every whatever week or two weeks.
And there was a Negro section. And so dad, it was one of the few literate people. And he wrote this section, advice to the men.
And so he was doing that. And while he couldn't say openly in that Bulletin, we know people are not fair here.
He focused on what the men needed to do to support their families. The need for the hard work for being your best.
And I think the message that they both were saying to me was the same message that so many black children heard, particularly in the deep South.
The world is not fair. We know that. So the question is, what do you do about it? You must be twice as good.
You will hear that over and over again. That don't expect fairness. But be twice as good. And perhaps you will be selected.
That was just the way of the world. Now the good part about that is you learn to work really hard.
And to focus on self-empowerment. You weren't expecting anybody to give you anything.
Which may sound old fashioned, but I quite frankly use the same philosophy of the students today.
Not so much about twice as good. Just working to be the best. But what I say is twice as good in the sense that Americans need to learn to work much harder than people from other parts of the world.
So it's the same thing for my white students. Is it about anyone else? Well my women's students, everybody. It's a great philosophy.
We're fans, members of the NAACP?
Oh yeah, very much so. NAACP, Alabama Christian movement. Oh yeah, very much so. Very proud members.
Your father's college degree was in what year?
Well, this is, it would have been something in education. Education. Mother always had, and was education due, but she was always with the focus in English.
Yeah. At the mill, about to move on from the some more active events in the 50s. But last question was, your father's age, without a put him just beyond that period when there was active.
And for a while, in a racial efforts to do union work inside the mills in butter.
I would not know he would not have been a part of no, no, no, no, not have been a part of that.
Tell me about it. And you had a newborn in the 50s. It would have taken a while. But somebody's thing sort of become your attention.
But what stands out in your mind is some of the first impressions of open social questions about race. Maybe towards the late 50s, of course, your young child.
Well, keep in mind that other than are going to separate schools and seeing those books.
When I think back, we were very protective in many ways for a long time. That was the significance of the Black Middle class community.
People work to give us as many experiences as possible to make us feel as special as possible.
It's only when we realize that was Kitty Land. You'll hear even my friend, Kandy, talking about this.
All of us were aware that Kitty Land was this great place with the big thres wheel and all the lights and all the children. And we'd all have to pass that.
I mean, you went to a certain part of Birmingham and imagine a child seeing all these kids in there having fun and we couldn't go.
That was devastating. We always. And finally, there was a small third-rate little place where you could go and have a party or something.
But it was nothing. That was ball with something. We got older and wanted to go to the movies.
Today, whatever we call the movie house, movie theater, whatever.
We had, of course, to sit in the balcony. Certain places to sit.
And then as we wanted to go to begin to go to restaurants or places, we had to go on a side door.
All we couldn't go in or we could go in and get it to go, but not order and sit.
And then when we went to stores to buy things, we could be doing something. If somebody white came up, we were too wait.
And so more and more of my parents decided that they would just keep us from doing those things after they realized the impact.
So we, even, I mean, the worst part was when you had to go to the restaurant and there was not. All you were thirsty.
And there was a wonderful, quite only, that looked pretty nice. Had a dirty, filthy little thing, lower and awful that we couldn't drink out of.
Those were the kinds of things that said in subtle and yet not so subtle ways.
We were a cast system. We were not equal.
Tell me a little bit more about your experience as a mental school student.
Are you percotious from the get-go?
Yeah, I was very fortunate. I think I was, I had old parents. My dad was 40 when I was born.
A lot of managers, they knew they wanted me. They put all their attention on me.
I was reading at a very young age and actually going to school at a very young age, very young age.
And I ended up finishing the first grade, just about to finish the first grade when I was four.
And the Negro superintendent was in the school. And I noticed that every time they had this VIP, I would be taken out of the class
and taken to the girls' restroom to hide.
And the reason was that this VIP Dr. Hayes, as he was Dr. Hayes, was my Godfather.
I'll be back to him but he had my mother and I should tell you, mother hid the pregnancy
a long time because if a woman was pregnant, then matter that she was married, she could not continue to teach.
And mother was thin at that time and she hid the pregnancy. She hid me with loose-fitting things up until almost April or May.
I was born in August and she loved the big joke, she always loved saying he was almost born in the classroom.
He was born to teach. She did not want me to be a principal, she didn't want me to be an administration.
She said he was born to teach. That's what, to her, that was the most noble thing you could do.
And one day when I was hiding in that bathroom, really frustrated and embarrassed to be in the girls, I ran out, I got a lift from the kid,
the big girl who was holding me in there and ran right into Dr. Hayes. And he said, why are you in school, Freeman?
And I said, I'm in the first grade, I'm about to grade. And that was not good, not good.
They took me out and they'd me go back to the kindergarten, but I already knew the word.
They brought me back to next year and hid me again because you still in first grade five.
So I spent my five when I was five teaching other kids, I always got a couple of slow kids and working with them on words and things to keep me busy.
So it was great enrichment, it really was. I was very fortunate. And I always say this, it was not that smart.
No, I just had great parents who were educated, attentive, knew how to teach. They emphasized reading and math, ideas, talking, they allowed me to discuss issues.
Any child who gets that background can move fast.
Shifting. Did you have a sense as a child about legal affordability in the city? Did you have a sense of the white government?
Did you have a sense of maybe what it would measure if at all a child and some measure wearing this or apprehension,
did you have a sense of the capacity of police to be violence, or those things?
Well, we had studied government and maybe the seventh grade. We knew about well as a name and we knew both common to police.
We understood something about relationships, tree and city government and managers and police.
We also knew that police were not fair either.
We had been stopped at different points and they were not nice.
My father looked international much more so. I always say he married a beautiful chocolate woman in here I am.
But daddy could pass for other things. He was well, all in a color, but rather straight and curly hair.
And he talked very fast. And so when the police would stop him and he always drove much too fast.
He talked much too fast. And they would stop him and they would say Mr. Robusky, slow down next time.
We're going to have to give you a ticket. Then they'd look over and see me looking like him, but obviously knowing what I was from the kinky hair and everything else.
Then they'd look back at him and then at his license and see the sea.
And all of a sudden they would go from Mr. Robusky, free when you're a color boy, as they began to write the ticket.
So the big joke, he always said, I was the best liability you ever had.
Did you, did you and the family take note conversation?
Otherwise about the explosion of sit-ins in February 1960 was that something that really...
Very frightening because people knew each other, families knew each other,
and the Revan Shadows were attorney shores. These are families knew each other.
And we really did care about each other. And if it could happen to the most privileged people, it could happen to anyone.
And they're in bomb hill in Birmingham. That's the other... That's Bithil, the other middle class neighborhood.
Where some of them went to our church, sisters and brothers of people lived on both sides.
And the mother was close to all these people. And there were...
Literally, even in the church, there was a north side group, and a south side group.
And again, the two middle class groups. And so it's hard to explain just how close the groups were.
So when there's a bomb, you immediately, immediately think it's right next door.
Because these are people you know. It's very frightening. Very frightening.
And we knew from decades about lynchings, about violence. We all knew.
And it was very frightening.
I mean, if you would, do you recall, May of 61, and I would love to see a few of my classes in the Birmingham community?
And all of that would have been discussed in church in different ways. And both in illusions in the sermon, but in youth fellowship.
One of the great things about my church was that we discussed ideas and books.
And I mentioned Connie, or her father, who was a Presbyterian minister, still worked though with Six Avenue.
And so he would help us with youth fellowship at Six Avenue either. And he was my high school counselor.
And we discussed all those matters. That's the one thing that was really...
We were developing critical thinking skills as we thought about the good and the bad and the ugly,
what if things were different, what are the consequences of these actions.
And all of that was... In many ways, elevating.
These things would not discuss as if it was just for today.
I was about what should a human being expect out of life?
What does American democracy mean?
I'll never forget when I had a talk with my principal in high school after the demonstration.
And he was being forced to put the kids out of school.
And I'll never forget his having some of us read the Rose Civil Disabilities.
It was just... It was amazing the way people got around all the bureaucracy when he was being told that he should be looking down on us.
When he was saying to us, that he put you out of school. He did something that was very special.
Instead of making it something that was embarrassing, he called the entire school together as one community.
And he conducted that session in exactly the way he had conducted the Unicensity Induction.
And it literally... It brings tears because he was absolutely brilliant.
He was determined that those of us being suspended would know it was a badge of courage.
It's a tell me this story of the spring of 1963. You're just 12 and a half years old.
And all of this just torn down.
Sure.
How did that history find you, the Analyst City, in those minds?
I think I told you we were always in church.
And I make students laugh sometimes because I say, I'm not going to paint that as a picture where we were.
So I happen to be there all the time.
And I did not want to go listen to these different people from outside talk.
I mean, and I'm sitting in the back of the room and the way my players could play Kate Mew was to let me just read my book.
I'll do my math. I love math.
And so I sit in the back of the church because you had to be there. And I'd listen to a bit of...
And you learned to sing the songs and the songs were good.
But amazingly, when I heard this man say that what he was proposing, and that is involving children in the march,
could lead to children being able to go to any... to the best schools in our city.
Now, that got my attention.
Because I wanted to see just how smart these white kids were.
I didn't think anybody was smarter than I was.
And to me, though, smart was not about what you're born with.
Smart had to do with how hard you were willing to work.
My parents had to sometimes punish me for not going to sleep.
I mean, I just wanted to keep working and they were worth it. I was working too hard.
And to me, that was smart.
When you work really hard and you achieve a lot and you make A's not because you want the grades or because you want to...
Dare to know.
But when he said that, I said, now, that's worth listening to.
And I said, what's this guy's name? What's his name?
He said, King.
This is my first time. I'll never forget.
I said, King.
Reverend Martin Luther King.
It was very amazing.
And then I began to listen to him and others.
And I realized how well spoken they were.
Now, as it turns out, my pastor was also very polished as a speaker.
He read a lot. We read books together.
So we were accustomed to polished speakers, but this man was talking about the next level.
What it would take to change things.
Because what we don't remember is that while we knew things were not fair,
we tended to think this is the way of the world.
I suppose it's the way my descendants felt in slavery.
It just is this way. It's awful.
But this is the way of the world.
And before that King message, that message from Dr. King,
the thought was, since this is the way of the world,
you've got to be really good to get a chance at all.
He was changing the model, the vision,
and saying, it doesn't have to be this way.
That we could be empowered to change it.
Very different message.
And did I believe him?
I wanted to.
Was I convinced it was going to happen?
Absolutely not.
If you've seen the world one way, all of your life,
even if it's just 12 years, it is the way it is.
The best you can do is have hope and try.
And that's what happened.
And I mentioned that we have this exhibition right now at this Smithsonian
for all the world to see done by one of my colleagues, Marys Berger, here at UMBC.
And a part of the message of that exhibition
is that the visual culture of the time had a greatly impacted people realize.
For the first time, people could see through TV,
exactly what was happening.
For the first time America saw the Fahos as the dogs, the children,
the children being absolutely abused.
And I'll never forget that first day that I saw that after hearing Dr. King,
I said, Mama, Dad, I've got to go.
And they said, absolutely not.
No way.
And I did something you just did not do.
I said then, you guys are hypocrites.
Well, you see, that may not sound like a big deal today,
but at that time you did not say disrespect for things to your parents.
My dad could not believe I said that.
He said, go to your room.
And stay there.
And it was the next morning that they had been up all night.
After that being up all night, they came in and said, I could go.
Now I tell my students all the time, by this point,
while I thought my parents were unfair, because my part was,
you've made me go to all these meetings.
I hear all this stuff.
You tell me to think for myself.
I'm thinking for myself.
I want to do the right thing.
I want to do what Dr. King, somebody you say you admire,
wants me to do, and yet you're saying no.
And they came in to explain.
It wasn't that they didn't trust me.
They did not trust me to be in that jail with those white people
who didn't care about our children, about black children.
And they said, you're our treasure.
We don't trust you to them.
And I understand it now.
I often ask myself, would I have allowed my child to go?
I'm not sure I would have.
But somehow they came in.
They had been praying.
Literally their eyes were red.
And we prayed together and we cried.
Now I was crying because I was worried about them, worried about me.
But great, Frank, all of a sudden I'd get really frightened.
I was like, oh my god.
And my cousin, who was in the other bed, was laughing
because he said, no way about letting those dogs bite me.
I am not going.
He was two years old and he said,
for him to give me stupidity he wants to.
So it wasn't that I was that courageous.
I did believe in the cause.
I had said I was going to go and I couldn't back out.
Let's just be honest about it.
I wanted to go, but I was frightened.
And this is what happens to people so often, right?
And because I was in a higher grade and kids,
below 14, went to the juvenile place.
They chose me.
And because I was asking a lot of questions in the little training session,
it chose me to lead a group of kids.
And I learned what that meant.
You were singing the songs, the leading people and singing the songs.
And you're keeping the kids from focusing on the police officers.
Because the police officers were training to try to upset us.
And if you ask any black kid, probably the white kid too.
Who is the one person that you really don't want anybody
talking about your mother?
And what were they doing?
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, they were just trying to upset us.
Because if they could show that we were throwing rocks
or doing something about it, then they'd be justified
in using the club or whatever.
But if we were just walking along,
it would be very hard to justify the violence.
We're back on that trip.
I'm a friend of the basketball team.
Let me ask you to even shift to a level of deeper, deeper, deeper.
Sure, sure.
That story of, I'm so interested in that sort of,
that not at home, but that.
Yeah.
Very difficult to look at, maybe.
And quite understandable.
You mentioned that you would be drawn in as a leader of a student training group.
And I love the training.
Can you stay at kind of that level of a sale and walk me through
how you entered in what you've already seen in the streets,
what was happening, where you had these meetings.
Yes, the training meetings were at 670 Baptist.
My church, which was the sister church.
And we'd be bust over to the other place.
And different people were telling us things to expect.
That some of the younger kids would get upset and become homesick.
We had to work to keep them quiet and calm.
We practiced the songs.
Ain't going to let nobody turn me around.
And we would, and it's amazing how singing those songs elevates you.
And gives you a high purpose.
I can still hear all these children singing these songs.
And keep on walking, keep on talking, watching onto Freedom Land.
And amazingly, it gave you the strength to keep going.
Just to keep going.
You didn't listen to the police.
You were looking at cameras.
You just focused.
And I was to get there.
And if allowed, I was to kneel with the kids and pray.
Pray for the right to be a first class American citizen.
That's all.
That's all we were asked.
And I cannot tell you how much my knees were shaking.
But the songs really helped.
And we did a lot of praying.
And it was very strong.
It was saying, just to God help me keep moving.
And we did it.
And we made it up to the steps.
And that's when this guy with this really red face looking so angry.
Looked out at me and said, well, you want a little nigger.
Oh, God.
I was so scared.
And I looked up at him and I said, so not serve, but so we want to kneel and pray.
And he was so angry.
He spat on me.
I would never forget it.
He spat in my face.
Pick me up and threw me in.
And they came and got the kids and they threw us into the paddy wagon.
You want to step so?
City Hall.
Right.
16th Street right there.
And it was just awful.
It was awful.
I was on a date.
Just in a day.
Take to the note.
Nope.
And another juvenile place with bars and big war fence.
And it put us in with the bad boys.
You know, and it was awful.
Before we got stayed five days.
It was awful.
But I was helping eight and nine years.
And a lot of the kids were not from middle class homes.
And I was just going to keep that thought that what we were doing was not universally accepted as the right thing to do.
There were many of my teachers and others and neighbors who felt kids should be in school.
Now who could argue with that?
So this was an experiment.
And when people say, well, you bothered that others were not agreeing, no.
No, my parents understood.
My teachers had been told, suddenly through the Board of Education, that the children of teachers,
if children of teachers went to jail, those teachers would lose their jobs.
The mother had lost it out before.
I should always believe God will provide.
But so they were and we end up in told people with mortgages and banks.
Mike, you know, it was your call.
It was amazing.
We might lose homes.
You just didn't know.
So you could understand people who had something already invested, not wanting to give that up for an experiment.
And so there were a few of us from the middle class neighborhood.
But not many.
Most of the kids were from the projects.
Understandably.
What is it that families have to lose?
Understandable.
But I think the advantage of that middle class situation was we had just a bit more exposure and could be supportive of other kids.
And those five days, did you see your parents?
No.
Could not. They would not allow parents.
There were, I remember that somehow there were bibles there though.
And when, and I was not the kind of kid who could protect kids physically.
It really was a fat math nerd.
Not chubby little kid loving blueberry pie math.
All right. That was my life.
I mean, heaven for me was eating some pie and doing math problems.
And bad boys.
And they were being encouraged to harass and beat up kids.
And the way I kept my kids, they always be with me.
Trying to keep them from crying.
But there were times when bad boys were coming out of direction and I'd start reading aloud from the Bible.
And I was like, this is my shepherd.
I showed that one.
And it always get the hell out of them.
And they would move back.
It was powerful.
It was great.
And I would just say, thank you so much.
Because I couldn't, I didn't know to fight.
That was not my life.
It just was.
But, and fortunately, there was a bad boy in there who had been in my mother's class.
And he was also very supportive of me when he realized what my name was.
I'll never forget that.
It really did help.
Yeah.
And that was that was that experience.
But the experience taught me was that even children can make decisions that can have an impact on the rest of their lives.
And the children know the difference between right and wrong.
And the children can suffer and be better for the suffering.
It wasn't awful experience.
It was so depressing.
It was, we were in the dark.
They let us out for an hour or two a day.
But it was just, it was gloomy.
These guards were always trying to make us feel worse.
And you'd hear them in there.
And you'd hear kids hollering.
You never knew what was going on.
It was, it was awful when I think back on it.
But one of those days when, maybe after three days or so, and families wanted to get their kids out, and Dr. King was saying, wait, he came with the parents.
And they were all outside.
And we were looking through the bars.
And they were singing the songs.
And he spoke.
And he said, what you do this day will have an impact on children getting going.
I never forget that.
I didn't even understand it.
But I knew it was powerful.
Powerful, very powerful.
And there are a nerds that are still raw, just from looking at the faces of the children, trying to understand what does that mean.
Powerful.
So what happens when you come out on the fifth day?
Oh God, you see your parents.
Wow, being a bright son, you realize how much we take freedom for granted.
We all do.
Just being able to go outside and walk around.
You really get to see what prisoners go through.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, just the freedom to do whatever you want to do.
Go to the store.
It was amazing.
It really was.
And I wanted to get back to school.
I was an A student.
I wanted to be in school.
And I'll never forget that as soon as we got back to school.
Well, I'll never forget.
We got back to school.
Within a day, we were back there.
And that's when the notice came.
We had to be suspended.
Oh, and suspension was like an embarrassment.
And that's why I say what the principal did made such a difference.
You were at what school?
Oldman High School.
At the principal was.
The principal was George C. Bell.
The reason the person who is most responsible for my becoming a mathematician.
He was a mathematician.
He was a brilliant guy of small statue and a big booming voice.
And when George Bell, Mr. Bell, spoke everybody listened.
And when a kid was not doing the right thing and he would boom down the hall,
that kid, I don't care how big would straighten up immediately.
But he was absolutely brilliant.
All right, just so happens that George Bell is the uncle of Alma Vivian Powell.
And my high school counselor, Reverend Rice, was of course the father of Condi Rice.
And so it was an amazing school with very smart teachers.
And a lot of kids who were very high achievers.
What was your, as those next few weeks to the end of May, on the day,
when you were in the middle of March,
finally, the children's come to the city actually a very hot period of a day.
Yes.
And I should tell you academically, Mr. Bell had worked quietly with teachers
to find ways to make sure kids could get homework at home.
This is really.
But what I will tell you is it was a very difficult period.
And what I remember is finally having the federal courts
to say put those children back in school.
And you can check this, but I'm almost sure the name, the guy's name was I write,
the guy's name I believe was Judge Black.
And we were in church when the news game.
And oh, just amazing.
You want to go like a victory?
Oh God.
Everybody cry.
It was just to know that somebody white in power knew that we were not wrong
and cared about children.
Just knowing that there was decency among white, made of big bits.
What are you doing?
Yeah.
Did you see anything else in the period that was like single time your arrested?
Oh yeah, yeah, very much so.
Yeah.
Did you see the witness other things that remained as just this flashing images
that just come to you when you think back on this stuff?
Oh my God.
It was that fall in September when, oh God, the flashes of the hand and the ring.
I mean, when one of my friends, when we were in church in September,
and things had begun to have signs of hope of opening up in Birmingham.
Remember all of the richness of my community, richness in terms of love and spirituality
and hard work and mutual support.
But you go downtown, I would go downtown.
I never saw one black in a position of power in downtown Birmingham.
Not even behind a cash register, little owner policeman or a farmer.
Nobody, everybody in any level of power was white.
And to have the city fathers deciding to compromise with Dr. King in the group
was a major victory and we said things have changed.
And we're in church that Sunday, September.
And all of a sudden, Pastor gets a note at the pulpit.
He stops preaching and tells us that that of a church, our sister church,
where relatives and sons and daughters and fathers and mothers have been born.
And didn't know how bad it was.
It was just a shock.
And he said, please don't rush out.
But it was the first time we'd ever seen church stop in the middle.
It had to be bad.
People started driving in that direction.
Mother and father took us home.
Because we didn't know whether that meant the next church was going to be born or whatever.
And as it turns out, I thought back to different friends.
One of whom was Cynthia.
And I'd seen her on Friday and I've said this before, I remember so well.
She was always very kind to me because I was younger than other classmates.
She was always very nice to me.
So that was 12, she was 14.
And she said, bye, Franklin.
Oh God, we said bye.
And it seems to me that she who said to you Monday.
And I knew she went to that church and mentioned so all these names.
And she was one of them, but I saw her face there at school.
And when one of the girls had been given a ring that morning by her father,
and they were not able to find her and then found that hand.
And we all, everybody knew that hand was that ring.
We had nightmares for years.
It was like war.
It was just awful.
My parents said to me when I asked if I could go to the funeral.
I could.
And I'll never forget.
I was to leave school.
My parents had given me and noticed.
And my principal saw me.
And this is education at best.
He came up to me and he said, you're representing us today.
And he looked at my tie.
And it was not dark enough.
Now you really was where dark ties to the venerals.
And he took his towel.
And took my towel.
He tied his tie.
It was amazing.
The small things people can do to make a child feel special.
And I'll never forget the three coffins with the nieces, the youngest of the three.
I think she was 11, McNair, in the middle, smaller.
I've never seen a coffin that small.
That small.
It was awful.
It was just awful.
And Dr. King said, what you know, he said,
life, I mean, what you need to know is that people who were the nieces were
saying that church was bombed, those girls were in those coffins because we went to jail.
We upset things.
And that's what happens.
And they tried to tell us how mean spirit and how awful people can be.
These were blacks, saying that.
And here's Dr. King back, taking responsibility.
And he looked into the faces of those parents and said, life is as hard as steel.
It's hard to see it.
In other words, I don't know what to say.
It is just so hard for all of us.
I just remember that.
I do.
I really do.
And I'll tell you what gave me hope in the midst of the darkness.
It was the first time I'd seen white too much of it.
There were rabbis and priests and Baptist ministers from...
Hmm.
Amazing.
And they...
Can you...
Yeah, give me a minute.
Ooh.
Yeah.
Give me a minute.
Just a...
Hmm.
Okay.
We're back on that for short break.
Let me ask you.
Yes.
It's just so difficult.
Yeah.
The distance is like a day sometimes.
Not like there's many, many years, but like...
Oh, yeah.
Maybe this is a good time to ask you a question of...
A difficult reflection.
And it's this.
Can you...
And there is no fixed answer.
I'm sure this question...
Sure.
I thought a little bit on the issue of how those kinds of experiences do take their long tolls.
And how you might gauge their implications in your life.
I'm reading a book right now where David Brooks, the social animal, and one of the points
of the book he talked about how we developed a lot of the books.
And I'm sure that David Brooks is a very good person.
And one of the points of the book he talked about how we developed a lot of relationships
and achievement is one of the points of the book is that we are all the products of our childhood experiences.
And when we least expect it, things that happen to us as children have an impact on us.
And so while we may think that what we do is the result of rational decision making, often circumstances and
previous experiences come together to push us in one direction or another without even realizing it.
What my parents worked to do after those difficult situations, what many parents worked to do,
was to help us get beyond the bitterness, the anger.
And even the hatred.
And what they said over and over again is hatred eats on the inside.
Hate the action or the act.
Don't hate the person.
I have to tell you when Bull Connor died, my mother called me and she was crying.
And I said, Mother, why are you crying about this man?
This man was awful to us.
And she said something that was so powerful.
She said, Freeman, but he was somebody's child.
All of what he did came because of how he was raised.
And for me, that was an amazing moment of enlightenment.
He was simply the product of his environment.
And it was cathodic for me.
Just let it go. Let it go.
And I have often thought about that moment.
My mother's way of giving me her faith in life itself and in humanity.
And it was also her way of saying, put your own experiences in perspective.
And a part of being educated is being able to give context to whatever experiences you've had.
And those of us who've been able to do that are much healthier as a result.
I really do believe those words of King that you judge people in the basis of content of character, not on race.
You can find good and bad people in any race.
And I'm here at the university with students from 150 countries.
And I've really come to understand what's coming among human beings from different cultures, different religions.
And that character can transcend all of that integrity, those kinds of things.
And so I think the reason I'm able to work so comfortably with my students from all kinds of backgrounds
is that I really can see beyond the obvious differences.
And look for not only what's in somebody's heart, but that person's ability to think.
And my life is focused on helping people to learn to do just that, to think well, and how to act with people,
and to get beyond what we sometimes believe are the most important things.
All right, how we look, to move to what, how we think and act.
I mean, not to summarize too much human, but it's probably a fair thing.
And I mean, this is a sincere compliment that your professional work has really has had the form of creating new ways for children to club and work.
I appreciate that.
Yeah.
And Mara Haft, so that's the truth.
Sure. Sure.
These are not small efforts.
I appreciate that.
I like the fact that this is a campus that really does talk about these issues of race and ethnicity, and works to create a climate,
in which people can say what they really think.
If you don't know a lot of people to say what they really think, then they're simply saying what's convenient.
And it doesn't get to the point of values.
And I think this is what we need in the American society.
We need opportunities for people, whether they are 50 or 15, to say what they really think.
We tend to believe what we've seen on TV.
If what you see on TV is violence, then you've seen certain groups looking like they're always doing things that are stealing and things that are bad, that's what you believe.
My students who are around all kinds of people are far more tolerant.
My students who come from areas where everybody looks exactly the same regardless of what race will tend to be far more comfortable, stereotyping, and assuming all people are the same.
And I think that's one of the things about education, is to teach people not just about people in this country, but around the world,
that we are the products of our childhood experiences.
Everyone of us has some good in us.
We can pull that out.
And those are the kinds of things I learned through that experience.
You moved from Birmingham in 1966?
You were good.
Yes, that's exactly right.
Now I should tell you, I spent a summer in different places.
Yeah, and I want to ask about that as well.
Yeah, before 1966.
I was in Massachusetts and I was 13 and I was going to the 11th grade.
And this was going to be my first experience in an all-white class in math and literature chemistry.
And it was clear, the education was so rich.
It was powerful.
It was rigorous.
It was challenging.
It was hard.
I loved it.
And when other kids would not raise their hands, raise my hand, just try the answer.
And it didn't take me long to realize not one teacher would ever call on me.
They would look right through me.
They would never mean they just, I wasn't there.
It was amazing.
So I always call it Rap Ellensons Invisible Man, okay?
But it was an awful feeling to feel totally unimportant.
In contrast to my old black school, where people were delighted that I wanted to try an answer.
When they would tease me and it pushed me and they would say, go for it.
None of that taught me the importance of teachers.
Teachers can either elevate us or even through a look, push us down.
And we see both in all kinds of situations among all races, depending on where you are.
And what I can say is I learned a lot.
When I came back to chemistry, I was well prepared.
I had finished the course that summer, all right?
Sending in math.
So I was really well prepared.
I had experienced also taught my parents that they were not willing to trust me to go to some of the predominantly white schools in the East who were interested in my attending.
They just didn't know.
And so I left in 1966 and I went to Hampton.
And because Book of Washington was a graduate of Hampton.
We respected Mr. Washington when he came to Bounta Ski, for generations.
And it was an amazing experience because half my teachers were white at Hampton, particularly in the math and science area.
And they were wonderful.
It was the first time I've been around white and they were so caring and decent.
And they were there to help those black kids succeed.
And it was then that I came to understand really a lot of nice white people.
And I was close to mathematicians and philosophers and it was great.
Did you come home to the summers to come home?
I came home in the summers, came home at Christmas time.
And the latter, and I actually decided after my freshman year to take a course at the University of Alabama, Birmingham.
I took the next calculus course just to see what it would be like.
And to see what education then, because some of my friends had gone to UAB and to Tuscaloosa,
and it was at all white class.
And to my amazement, what I had found at Hampton became even more understandable.
At Hampton, I learned that while I was best in my school and the top group in an A student
that I was not as well prepared as black children who had gone to either prep schools
or to very integrated white schools in the North.
Now, I told you nobody's going to work harder than I do.
And the girl at the time that I liked was getting the top score.
She was a jammer. She championed for the state.
She had had Latin, which I hadn't had. She was just much better prepared.
And so I said openly one day when she got 100, I'm going to marry her one day.
And I did, by the way, four years later.
But I was not as well prepared. It was clear to me that our education had not been as rigorous.
I had enough education, though, that I could work so hard I could still get all A's.
But they were not the highest A's. That first year I had to work on that.
But I came back to you, and I wanted to see how well prepared those kids were, the white kids.
And this was in the Cal 2, Cal 3 course or something, Cal 3.
And it turned out that the average in the classes was maybe in the 60s
and I always got 9, 8 to 100.
And the guy finally came up to me, quite professing.
And he said, where are you from?
Because I was making 8 classes.
I was just about what I came to understand was it wasn't just that the education for black kids was not what it should have been.
Those white kids from Alabama were not well prepared.
Years later, as I look at some of my tests, I see exactly that.
But I had no idea. I always thought the education was so much better.
No, no, was not the case.
And interestingly enough, I think back we had some really good teachers, some of whom had gotten grad degrees in Northern states
because they couldn't get them there.
So we had a solid education.
And I had better than most because of the other experiences from Massachusetts and NSF program at Tuskegee.
My parents were constantly giving me these extra experiences.
And we read everything.
So that was really solid.
We were reading all the time.
When I say it was not as well prepared, I had had through pre-calculus, but my top kids at Hampton had had calculus in high school.
I had an head calculus.
So when they took it and I was taking it for the first time, they had already had all of that.
Those kinds of experiences.
But my point is, we all suffered because of segregation.
When you've got to put everything separate, different administrations, you're spending money away.
It should have been on those kids.
And I realized not just black children, but white children when I get into the best of either.
Tell me about how you watched Birmingham of all.
I guess beginning in 66, it'll be this kind of pattern.
Yes, yes.
Because you're in college and then graduate school and you're just after that.
I guess it's probably a pattern of periodic visits.
Regular?
So over the years, your parents live in the United States.
Sure, sure.
I just think of sitting in hell, you watched the city change from that kind of lens.
It's interesting.
I saw more and more of my students, my friends, going to predominantly white schools in Alabama, to UAB, to Excluso, Auburn,
and becoming connected to those places, while others continue to go to the HPC use.
But I think I was most proud, I was really proud of Birmingham when Richard Errington became the mayor.
Because how many cities have a PhD in science as a mayor?
That's it, so much about progress we had made, really did it.
And I continued to know my city primarily through my church, 6th Avenue.
And more and more people were moving to UAB, doctors, people in mid school, and it come often to 6th Avenue.
And I saw this influx of people moving to Birmingham because of the university, the biggest employer, and well-educated people.
And I saw those changes at the same time.
I was assuming that the violence I saw in northern cities was not occurring in places like Birmingham, because it wasn't that level of violence among blacks on blacks.
Until I got back there and saw the same thing I saw in cities in this area, I saw there in Birmingham.
So on the one hand, you get the progress, more educated people going to the universities.
On the other hand, you've got the underclass killing each other.
Same challenge as your face, wherever you go in the country.
And it was that dichotomy that was and continues to be a major problem.
Of course Birmingham's demographic shift, because the city boundaries aren't that big.
And this is happening at the 6th Avenue.
Yes, and people have moved, that's exactly right, into the suburban areas.
And more and more, the Birmingham city schools have become black.
And before Phillips and other places that were white and yet a few black kids.
Some people said, why didn't I go to integrated schools?
I think I was in the 10th grade when we finally had integration.
And again, my mother simply didn't trust me to be in a school with teachers who didn't want me there.
And I remember so well when my friends went to my church, integrated, ramsy high school.
And Phillips, there were all kinds of problems.
But in those moments of desecrification, just as was the case with the University of Alabama,
very decent whites were there, parents.
And they became violent. They threw things at these children.
You saw the worst of humanity.
And understandably, my parents did not want me being a part of that.
No. Even if the education was supposed to be better.
My parents who had been teachers knew was, if teachers don't want you there,
you don't get the best education. You just don't.
Now, there were some decent people there, of course.
But how would you know who's willing to get beyond prejudice and just help a child?
That was the issue.
Tell me about your effort to create the model of scholarship.
And what that does.
Sure.
What that vision is.
When I went to the University of Illinois after graduating from Hampton,
I noticed that, of course, there were no black faculty.
And there were only several of us in mathematics, and others were not doing well.
And people didn't expect me to do well.
I remember I tell my students this story all the time.
I earned an A-minus on a test in topology.
And the professor wrote on my paper, you did surprisingly well.
Now, remember I said my mother was in English, and so I went up to a math class,
and I said, why the adverb?
And he didn't know what I was talking about at first.
And I pointed to the word, he said, return red.
And he said, well, it's because you're from a small school.
No.
It was at that point I remember that second grade experience.
I could decide I'm a victim.
The man doesn't expect me to do well.
Let me get out of here.
And I remember that same statement.
No time to be a victim.
Don't let this man define you.
And by the end of the semester, he was feeling so guilty.
Not just about the word, but about not telling me the truth.
The fact was he had never seen a black in a graduate course in mathematics.
And everything he knew about blacks would suggest they would not do well.
And I didn't know.
In his class, but more important than that, he got to know me as a person.
And I got to know him.
Who wasn't that he was a bad person.
We expect from people what we're accustomed to see.
And that was all it was.
But all of that showed me that we had a problem.
You don't have many blacks in math and science.
When I went around the country trying to find one predominantly white university
that was educating at least 10 people a year.
And all of science engineering, there were gone who would go into grad school to find one.
And fortunately, I had met Bob Mahal, who is not black, he's Jewish, and a philanthropist.
And we had conversations about black males and he wanted to make a difference in that group.
And we married the two ideas of black males, under-representation in science,
and started this program with that.
And I towards seeing what can we do.
Can we create a program that has those elements necessary to ensure that students of color
would not only succeed but excel in science and engineering.
And we were defining exceling as doing so well that they could go on and get PhDs
from the best universities in the country, an MD PhD.
And it has been an amazing journey since 1989.
And now we have hundreds and hundreds who've actually earned PhDs, an MD PhDs.
We actually now have students with those degrees on the medical faculties of Harvard and Stanford, Duke.
Even you may be hopkin, you know, Michigan all over the country.
And so the numbers are growing all the time.
So it's a dream fulfilled.
It really is.
And for many scientists, it's the first time they've seen large numbers of students of color
exceling in science.
Not just the exception of one.
That's the idea.
We've had an exceptional one since Tuskegee and George Washington cover.
Now it's time to have many more.
And so working with the national academies on these issues,
I have had a chance to chair most recent committee and to look at what we're going to need to do to take the numbers to the next level.
And all of that comes as a result of when you think about it, when I think about it,
of the hope I got from those experiences as a child.
And that the notion again, and I've never said it this way before,
that just because it's this way doesn't mean it has to be this way.
Now when we were doing the mile-haul,
it never occurred to me to say that,
and yet all those experiences from before,
if we could move from my not being able to sit in a classroom with whites,
to my being president of a definitely white university,
from age 12 to age 40 and 30 years,
why couldn't we move from having no blacks with Chisines and Science to having many?
So it's amazing how one experience does inform another.
That's very interesting even to me.
That is really how I feel.
Yes, yes.
Thank you for all this, Jess.
Let me invite you to reflect a little bit here as we close on
how you take the measure of history,
you look through, and you've thought so much about,
and the work you're doing now,
and how you knit those two things together to define your working vision of your job.
You know, in 1963,
only about 2% of African Americans had complete college.
Today, we're moving to a 20%, 17%, 18%.
But you didn't need a college education to get a good job.
Today, you need more education.
What was the civil rights movement really about?
Well, in very basic terms,
it was about people wanting to have the opportunities that all other Americans have.
But it really is about more than opportunity for this reason.
Today, people have the opportunity to go to college,
and yet, lot don't.
So what's missing here?
It's about having families and communities that focus on education,
and on values, and on dreams,
and the connection between hard work and reaching the dreams.
This is where we are challenged today.
Many families, black and white,
don't necessarily know what they need to do to help their children
to develop the skills they need, the values,
so they can get the education.
And without the education, they continue to be in the underclass.
And so for privileged people of any race,
all kinds of opportunities are available.
So for those of us in that top group, 25-30%,
things are much better.
They really are.
And if we're not careful,
we forget about those at the bottom.
There is the challenge that we face
to not be duped into thinking these things don't matter anymore.
I would say race still matters,
but I would add on, I mean, it's concerned about poor white children
and as black children, that in either case,
unless somebody teaches those children to read well,
the future won't be bright.
That's the issue we face.
And history has taught us the focus on education and values
and how we can make all the difference in the world.
Thanks, sir.
So generous to invite us here.
It's been a time with us. It's been great.
It has been a privilege for me. You are quite good.
Both of you. Both of you. It's amazing.
It's amazing.
The videographer has such sensitivity, such, I mean, I felt him.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African-American history and culture.